à mondeville
si on essaie quelque chose des prix de
l'eau aujourd'hui leur faim qu un cas
mouvement-là genre iroquois on a eu des
petites nattes comme beau derrière
non non non non sept membres aux chaînes
classiques comme d'habitude vous
rigolerez avec une autre cliente la
télévision voilà moi qu'est ce que j'ai
mangé s'est pas défilée j'étais prête à
exploser
faut dire que là d'un plus au foie gras
plus et chocolat plus et marron glacé
aucun encore 1 arlette non je veux ça va
être tout de suite aller 10 heures du
matin alors l'idée même de la nourriture
par match et camoufle suis comme vous
tenez normes présenterez on présente les
andouillettes au chablis bas serait
capable de vous venir sur la tête si
j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
qu'est-ce que tu n'aides ball à l'oeuvre
au noir noir noir tu fais pas ma cuisine
comme ça ça coûte moins cher il est
rigolo comme vivre c'est un livre de
marguerite yourcenar
ah bah moi je n'ai vu à la télé avec son
mari ou d'un flic avec carmen francis
lopez alors je crois pas non mais si la
tv la grande rose clame jean romano mais
en plus distingués écoutez arlette alors
là vous êtes gentille à vous laisser
finir on chapitre ajuster sa maman
accord pendant qu'ils brillent un v8
mireille mathieu est solide avec patrick
duffy rheineck ont du bol avec qui sa
bobine quoi le feraient rage hier j ai
coup de poing diabolise le regardais pas
dallas ballon c'est justement je regarde
pas d'as au on va dedans moi c'est ça
que j'aurais voulu être actrice
mais ma mère l a pas vu cela dit pas
d'importance a peut être pas fuir avec
ses poils du pass en coin à tripoter des
cheveux gras
audi dont tu veux gras fromages soigné
pour des problèmes en ce moment parce
car moi le jour je me suis disputé avec
mon jus le résultat la motte de beurre
mou c'est pareil à regarder mais
regardez le toucher frangy non non mais
touché je vous dis pas c'est pas grave
tenez regardez s'attache à vallet
oui donnez moi un petit peu de coton
s'il vous plaît merci
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
je peste la radio
plus d'amateurs encore des dames au
salon
alors qu'il dame du couteau par deux
complices ont comme d'habitude
asseyez vous si vous brûlez là vous
voudriez des bottins a pour nom sont
remis un livre avec des images mais ça
c'est sûr mais je vais lui dire merci
alors la tête comme ça s'il vous plaît
et puis là si vous êtes comme julie
français vont encore devoir se serrer la
ceinture ce mois ci c'est de faire un
livre ou non mais une pure sinon ça me
ferait pas de mal à domicile ans c'est
formidable
moi j'aimerais être voyez là je me
verrai à 6 face à la mer au bas des
falaises sur les galets alors vous
imaginez la glace et la mer le fauteuil
c'est les rochers on est sur la plage on
écoute la mer on la ferme
imagination je vais vous dire un truc
c'est pas possible au salon non mais
c'est vrai une cliente si on lui parle
pas les bras qu'on me fais la gueule
alors c'est moi je vous rassure là
dessus je vous en voudrez pas du tout
d'accord mettez vous savez bien comme ça
voilà tourner la tête
je suis fier j'aime bien oui qu'est ce
que vous disiez j'ai 59 ans se voit pas
du tout il a 18 ans mais non je lis la
c1 neuf ans il a 18 ans pouvons-nous
être heureux c'est plus rare que ce sera
dur
et j'aime bien avec les coyotes on sera
content d'être active
les maris les ombres vous êtes mariés
vous oui non oui mais non vous n'êtes
pas d'enfant 6 4 contre les îlots quel
âge 20 ans tous les cas oui voilà quand
vous étiez jeune la flamme était bavard
il l'a crûment ceux-là mais au fort
thermostat 7 il avait à voir des vip
lettre voici ce rare des pipelettes et
wilma peut voir comme un meilleur bond
si je rentre de pipelette
je veux un truc à quand une cliente unis
comme ça toujours comme d'une commune
pipelette
et ben moi tu me schémas techniques que
j'allais je leur laisse pas place et une
je parle tout le temps mais ces machines
là comment il s'appelle or c'est bien ce
qu'il faut de l'otan glen là même qui
l'ont influencé nos missiles n'avait pas
commandé alors machine elle s'appelle
lady di et sur la place du barry mann et
délits et ben moi je vais vous le dire
parce que le déguste on attendait de
vous faire la main comme les noms ne se
posera
mais c'est pareil avec cassano coiffure
la fin que ce soit le millas qui tombe
dessus
on serait tombés sur la page de yul
brynner monde raser la tête